it was a violent forceful shove which a
jury believes cost Ian Tomlinson his
life they are disturbing images which
the newspaper vendors finally had to sit
through countless times as the inquest
examined the final moments of his life
in agonizing detail after a month of
evidence but just four hours of
deliberation they found that PC Simon
Harwood had used excessive and
unreasonable force in hitting the 47
year-old he had the jury said been
unlawfully killed we think the jury
finding speaks for itself and the
verdicts of our local killers we had the
DPP will consider what the jury has said
in their evidence and that was come out
we're looking forward to the next stages
in the search for justice for Ian Ian
Tomlinson had simply been in the wrong
place at the wrong time trying to make
his way home he found himself caught up
in the g20 protests in the heart of the
City of London CCTV and other camera
footage showed him trying various routes
home but each time being turned back at
police cordons and around the same time
PC Simon Harwood was in the thick of the
protests he was also caught on camera
involved in at least two other
confrontations before his clash with mr.
Thomlinson here he's seen pushing a BBC
cameraman to the ground
misconduct